y en directo a América tenemos más
noticias económicas de la mano de
nuestro periodista especializado en el
tema Juan Pablo lucumín Juan Pablo
bienvenido de regreso acá estamos otra
vez acá estamos otra vez y lo hacemos
comenzando con la noticia financiera del
momento y es el rescate que hicieron
once bancos estadounidenses a First Bank
Así es fueron en total 11 entidades como
lo acaba de decir usted las que
inyectaron en conjunto total 30 mil
millones de dólares para el rescate de
French que vive una crisis de liquidez y
con el ánimo de evitar que siguiera el
camino de silicon Valley Y signature
ambos bancos también de Nueva York la
crisis del fuerza pública ha generado
preocupación en el congreso
estadounidense y el resto del mundo esto
a pesar de Pues el mensaje de
tranquilidad del Ejecutivo en los que
aseguran que todo está bien los 11
bancos que pusieron dinero fueron los
siguientes y los veremos a continuación
en un momento el principal o uno de
ellos Morgan Bank of America el City
Club también estos en conjunto que estos
son los más grandes de Estados Unidos
tuvieron inversión de 5 millones esto
cada uno
2500 millones de dólares para el caso de
Sax y Morgan Stanley y el resto los
otros 5000 fueron distribuidos en los
pues bancos más pequeños pero también
cabe mencionar que la empresa matriz de
silicon Valley incautada la semana
pasada por los Estados Unidos está
solicitando la protección por bancarrota
del capítulo 11 tanto la empresa como
sucedió fueron objeto de una demanda
colectiva esta semana debido a que
supuestamente la compañía no reveló los
riesgos que los futuros aumentos de las
tasas de interés tendrían en su negocio
un rescate entonces de 30.000 millones
de dólares una cifra por supuesto
bastante grande aunque no tanto si se
tiene en cuenta que es para un banco Le
quiero preguntar Cuáles fueron las
reacciones bueno reacciones que hubo en
Asia en Europa y en América Latina
Aunque internamente el gobierno
estadounidense niega la crisis que para
el resto de pues Es evidente por la
elevada inflación el aumento de tasas y
todo el problema por el techo de la
deuda otros países aseguran estar más
fuertes que la principal Economía del
mundo el gobernador del banco de Francia
dijo este viernes en el canal bfm que
los bancos de Europa son extremadamente
fuertes como para que ocurra algo
parecido a lo sucedido con Estados
Unidos recordó que desde la crisis
financiera 2008 las reglas en Europa se
han reforzado agregando que en Estados
Unidos no ocurre lo mismo ahora en
América Latina fue el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador quien aseguró a
diferencia del pasado que a diferencia
del pasado ahora lo que pasa en Estados
Unidos no afecta tanto al resto del
mundo escuchemos les puedo decir que
ahora
no es como en los tiempos del
neoliberalismo
que en efecto no
les daba gripa en Estados Unidos y aquí
nos daba pulmonía ahora es al revés
allá pueden quebrar los bancos como está
sucediendo y aquí no pasa nada Juan
Pablo Cuáles son los indicadores
arrancamos con una noticia que le puede
interesar a nuestros televidentes Y es
que Ford llamará revisión más de 1,5
millones de vehículos en Estados Unidos
en dos acciones para reparar mangueras
de frenos con fugas y brazos de
limpiabrisas que pueden romperse ahora
vamos a las bolsas asiáticas que
registraron ganancias en sus principales
indicadores con Los líderes de Japón y
China diciendo que la inestabilidad en
el sistema bancario de Estados Unidos no
afectará para nada esa parte del mundo
el panorama es completamente opuesto en
las bolsas europeas que siguen operando
en su mayoría la baja mediadas por las
protestas de la Reforma de pensiones en
Francia y el dato de inflación de la
zona Euro Y cuéntenos cómo fue esa
inflación pues hubo una leve reducción
de la tasa si se compara con la de enero
esto debido a que la caída en los costos
de energía fue compensada por el aumento
de los precios en la en casi todas las
demás las demás áreas
de los 20 países que comparten el euro
pero si revisamos la inflación
subyacente que es la que excluye los
precios de los alimentos y los
combustibles porque son muy volátiles el
indicador en febrero saltó hasta el 5,6%
desde el
5,3%, según datos de la casa de
estadísticas europea eurostat Gracias
Juan Pablo por toda la información
económica